[Musique]
jean-philippe vous avez dû en tournée
l'ibr puis d hamlet
va tester des applications qui sont
assez
la maison
jean-philippe monette chef enseignant à
l'idée est ce qu a tenté de trouver le
modèle idéal pour la cuisine il a testé
pour nous ses spatules entre deux îles
70 dollars je les déserts sont tellement
variés c'est tellement particulier
des seize mois de répit d'acheter les
moyens aujourd'hui le symbole en soi
à l'aide de quelques aliments aimé
cuisiner jean philippe a tourné soulevé
pressé il portionné
dans notre lot trois types de spatule
la spa cela poisson qui est souvent très
rainurés soir mais tu as commencé tôt
droit donc ça va nous permettre de
rentrer assez directement sur le produit
comme
une spatule c'est aussi plus courte avec
une tête sans rien leur clip ils veulent
par exemple eh ben il va ordi d'espacé
l'oci qui va avoir un an j'ai un peu
plus long aussi ça nous permet de nous
éloigner du feu donc si vous travaillez
au gaz
pas toujours évident d'avoir quelque
chose qui va bien manoeuvré tu vois bien
un sprint massif je veux donner à ces
supports est ce qu'on a le besoin le
choix du matériau est un critère
important
il y a les spatules en inox pour les
poils on en est allé en alliage et il y
à des spectacles en matériaux composites
nylon mélamine silicone conçu surtout
pour des poêles anti-adhésives le
convaincant avec les matériaux
composites et on a rarement une grande
finesse on a toujours un peu plus
d'épaisseur
donc s'arrêter un peu plus difficile se
profilait mais si vous voyez déjà là il
commence à rendre courbure beurre qui se
joue avec un an à port harcourt b de
plus en plus elle était droite au départ
ok d'âcre et déjà commencé à corriger
attention aux spatules avec matériaux
composites qui ont tendance à fondre
dans la poêle
abstrait c'est le camp qui boucle le
résultat mais au sol la mélanienne le
milan
c'est qu'on veut pas se faire
attendre bush
ici j'ai la guitare d'eau qui est un peu
la forme d'un espace où la boisson
traditionnelle est en nylon mais son nom
qui est très rigide je parle pour
presser congrès de schiste c'est parfait
le sache a très bien ça se joue bien
c'est tout le contraire pour la cuisine
pro très flexible un peu trop même
soulèverait pas le poisson comme
catapulte
la boulette de hamburgers ah oui quelque
chose qui va être assez résistant au
nouveau pont j'ai soulevé humaine plus
la classique spatules à casse croûte
comme la sabatier et bien sûr inévitable
mais une spatule troué comme la norme
rohs ou rainurés comme les wheeling
peuvent être intéressantes pour évacuer
le gras dans la poêle si j'ai vraiment
mon modèle en trayant bleus
c'est
bien aussi mais c'est un bon départ
a précisé l'odm importance
[Musique]
pour tourner ses craintes et ses yeux le
chef peine un peu avec les spatules plus
rigide plus courtes ou plus et pex avec
des passions plus rigide plus petit
évoquons
ici on ne la silice est un étrange
compromis l'idée est bonne sur papier
c'est à dire s'il compte sur une spatule
en poisson pour éviter dans be built
échelon mais comme ça donne un peu plus
d'épaisseur des fois ça va être un peu
plus si vous êtes déçu d'apprendre un
instrument
je vais dangereusement
mais si j'ai un poêlon que je ne veux
pas habillé laquelle serait idéal reste
à la maison pour quelque chose comme la
rock se situe à aurait dit bill t je
vais me permettre de me faufiler mais
encore là je la trouve encombrants le
problème c'est un
peu
[Musique]
l'âme elle s'élève midi c'est la joie
n'est quand même pas
sortir le premier morceau du gratin de
la lasagne
t-il en particulier pour
l'idéal ça serait ça serait quelque
chose comme la sa bâtisse il faut c'est
vraiment con pour avoir tassé coûtant
pour aller briki comme elle est très
courte
c'est solide ça va être facile d'aller
chercher notre morceau ici notre chef
rejette d'emblée les spatules rainurés
qui ne serait pas pratique pour bien
transporter la source et des morceaux
malgré que les spatules à pois cents
soit moins efficace pour portionné quand
il s'agit de travailler dans une poêle
en fonte en acier inoxydable ou en
cuivre notre chef n'a d'yeux que pour la
rouste of the c'est sûr que pour moi là
l'idéal c'est la loose tard mais
historique absolument aucun bon sens le
à 110 dollars c'est ce que l'on va
mettre une deuxième hypothèque pour
racheter ce bâtiment il ya plusieurs
modèles qui existent sans du magasin
s'est passé de trouver quelque chose de
plus abordable
au final il n'y a pas de spéciale
parfaite mais les wings et très bien
démarqué parmi les spéciales ont composé
dans l'ensemble je trouvais qu'elle
avait bandé judith et pas trop gros ça
pourrait bien manoeuvré très confortable
en main les renner était très film ce
qui fait que on à l'écoulement des
droits par exemple mais en même temps on
peut on peut même y publie quelque chose
qui ne peut plus vite il je trouvais
qu'elle était vraiment utile pour faire
à peu près n'importe quoi
[Musique]